pieces and here we go and here we go
it's not some georgia's day anymore but
it's the english opening instead
and uh magnus carlsen pushing his c pawn
forward um he's been kind of just
experimenting with a whole variety of
openings so far in the oslo esports cup
and here we go white bringing a night
out maybe not having expected this
opening for magnus carlsen yet she goes
for the move i was expecting
this one that giri has played many times
before and magnus
now going for the four nights variation
of the english and a set of trades
it's called the reverse dragon the
system because it's like a dragon
sicilian but we're
with reverse colors white having an
extra move
and uh still very well known stuff from
both players and niche about to push the
black h-pawn forward
and uh yeah a theoretical battle between
them who's done the better homework
that's the big question i didn't like
giving away the space advantage when i
had the white pieces and you can sort of
see that black already has a pawn uh
farther further advanced than white and
that just wasn't something i enjoyed
doing this bishop move that magnus just
played the two were actually repeating a
game that they had played against each
other in 2019 in the gasham memorial um
magnus has never played this but a niche
has definitely faced it interesting so
anish clearly
having studied this position before
magnus must have done right if he's
raced into this position he must have
studied any previous games that's what
the top players do we talk about
training camps opening preparation and
okay after just a little bit of thought
anish centralizes his rook
and uh i'm sure i'm sure it happened
somewhere probably not the british
championships and
all the players went to castle at a
certain point and uh anish retweeting
his queen
didn't i have a favorite opening because
i do listen to the best chess players
every day talk about chess but i'm
having a hard time memorizing those
openings i got got a fair few yeah one
chessbourne the last one that came out
was um the life and times of mikhail tao
so it's actually
him he wrote this one and he's one of
their most interesting chess players my
favorite chess player of all time okay
bass players just kind of marking out
their territory we haven't talked so
much about the last few moves because
both players were just kind of improving
their pieces slowly if you look at
white's army here it's all kind of
camped out on the first three ranks uh
not really
kind of pushing forward yet not really
initiating that kind of action between
the two uh two sets of forces black
meanwhile spent a lot of moves with the
queen that's why we normally say don't
bring your queen out too early because
black had to use a couple moves to
retreat her to a safe square
just to make sure she wouldn't get
hit by a set of bishops maybe hit by
some pawns and now magnus with this last
pawn push just getting ready to expand
and push white's pawns forward on this
left flank i think karpov played quite
often um and i know that because my
friend adam hunt beat me with this idea
once and uh he told me it was the
carport version but he could have been
fibbing
he just beat me and pretended he was
carp and i was like yeah i believe you
but similar kind of thing happening
anyway david here
in the game uh night forks later to
worry about but it's all about the
diagonals and the white bishops do look
very good on these two diagonals right
now the black queen was attacked
certainly has found a safe square for
her in the middle of the board still a
lot of action yet to come and okay
magnus starts by choosing to offer a
trade of bishops
okay and no trades yet
and he says you can do it but on my
terms he pushes forward and magnus doing
the same the minority attacks is coming
these two are going to undermine black's
three pawns over here but i agree with
you vancouver i mean that white has this
easy plan uh the minority attack of
opening up the light square bishop just
trying to win a pawn on the queen side
positioned into the center to get rid of
white's very strong uh bishop in front
of his king and yeah so forced moves
yeah like that in chess it's like fair
enough yeah chess is like warfare after
all and yeah the queen on a different
square and he's now maybe trying to
trade off the bishops on this diagonal
magnus meeting that
by attacking the black queen interesting
so he's attacking the black queen and if
we see black block with the bishops how
is magnus going to keep the bishops on
the board now um he's keeping the
balance i think i think we might be oh i
was going to say we might be able to
about see a repetition of moves but no
magnus trades things off and okay he's
lured the black queen to this square
because he wants to create a pin on the
fourth rank is what is the thing it
comes not just
persian word for i think tower i think
but uh okay meanwhile a couple of moves
the black queen we mentioned was
uncomfortable on that fourth rank so
she's gone back to reposition herself
and uh not too much else has changed so
now i'm expecting magnus to start
pushing pawns on this left flank because
he's a bit stuck it you know it's on
that open file and he's played done it
okay so uh so it wasn't irrelevant all
the stuff we were talking about there
is in the position black can actually
capture this pawn as if it just moved
one square and to take or not to take
that is the question it looks on
anisha's screen like he is about to go
for it there we go ompassant did happen
queen trade very quickly and white
recaptured the pawn so before in ancient
times the bishop was an advisor to the
king ah so you know the bishop sits next
to the king
okay so that makes sense that's that's
why that definitely it's good to be
curious yeah so you wouldn't actually
say that chess is perfect and also it's
a magnus position right magnus loves
playing against small strategic uh
problems which a niche has i mean i
guess it is yeah we go for
it's a nine minute advantage for the
world champion and we know he's not
feeling well magnus carlsen but this is
the type of position this is his bread
and butter this is what he's uh
specialized in since he was young and
anisha's just got his strategy all wrong
okay he pushes a pawn forward now you're
stopping any kind of rook checks maybe
the white rock on the fourth rank was
about swing over but now there is a
target uh for the white rook and
anish it's really hanging by a thread
for him already trades one set of rooks
but that only improves white's pawn
structure anish has gone into his
opponent's home territory anish clearly
uncomfortable he has to use his rook to
defend his pawns now on this fifth rank
but magnus can step a pawn forward in
the center and okay magnus brings his
rook across defends his bishop look how
flexible white's pawn structure is as
well white can push pretty much any pawn
if he wants to black's pawns are all
pretty much fixed because in a pure rook
end game his pawns would be even weaker
black's rook is stuck on the fifth rank
just doing a defensive job so he has to
play with his king alone uh first he's
going to push pawns he's going to try
and kind of force gary to trade off
these bishops
even if you're really unwell you can
play a position like this even if you're
really tired you can play a position
like this
very much to the middle in all our
matches
i'm gonna say now i'll be shocked if
magnus doesn't win this i know he's not
feeling 100 but
just look at his last few moves he
pushed a pawn forward in the center
solidifying everything and now the white
king
kind of making its way towards those
isolated weak doubled black pawns
especially if magnus is sneaky and gives
him a chance to
like break out but it was a false
promise okay so the bishops have been
traded we did speak about that you know
that there is the urge to do something
the bishops are off um which pawn should
capture the bishop
kind of look nice
look nice he's got to be 100 sure there
that he's winning uh so you don't go
into a king and pawn end game unless
you've calculated every single detail
and maybe it wasn't so easy for white to
create a past pawn in that endgame and
uh this will tie down the black rook
okay the black rook has actually gone
back already to defend this pawn uh
preempting that the other potential
weaknesses are these ones but the black
king is holding them for now
so really interesting okay magnus okay
we are actually heading towards this
position magnus he does have that
question is he going to for example
reroute his king round this way
uh to attack this pawn on the edge of
the board which is isolated is he going
to maybe maneuver his king around the
other way and then free up his rook and
kind of overload the black army anish
meanwhile just has to move back and
forth yeah sitting on his hands he's
doing that but 30 seconds just re-route
it to the offline as david showed oh i i
didn't expect black just has to move his
rook back and forth on this seventh rank
it's just going to use these squares and
wait and okay magnus he's going the
other way round now but what's next for
magnus that's the big question we know
that magnus doesn't believe in
fortresses but anishigiri has tried to
set up a fortress he's hoping that white
can't break through
and okay white is just waiting anish is
just going to rotate with his rooks back
and forth as we mentioned can
potentially move especially the d pawn
and
he's just maybe at the right moment
going to play this and i like the idea
he showed earlier david bringing the
white rook to the f-file hitting uh but
yeah it's going to be hard for a niche
every move magnus is going to start
creating tiny little mini threats and
anish is going to have to
burn his time trying to counter them
yeah once magnus has started to create
those threats first magnus is just
improving his king then he'll improve
his rook and then the threats might
start to come or the pawn breaks at
least uh as you guys mentioned
yeah look at what anish is doing just
king up king back king up king back it's
horrible playing now isn't it
in some respects especially when you're
playing magnus it's like oh dear team
actually should probably be playing
drafts
oh simon your move is on the board the
breakthrough has happened is it the
right moment that's the big question and
giri clearly surprised by that because
it looks like white's giving up a pawn
and okay he's not going to take this
pawn off the board oh he is that pawn
which is too strong you couldn't let it
march forward but now this is the point
the white king has entered the game and
magnus has timed it pretty well i think
because the black king is offside
black's king is kind of on the wrong
part of the board right now and uh oh
gary look at that he clicked on his rook
looking clicked on his king under 10
seconds he hasn't he's not sure what to
do
oh he took a passive decision as well oh
the white rook is in now the white rook
is in the black camp
and uh white can actually think about
advancing the seaport in one square
forward i don't like that movie i
thought the black king had to come back
towards but
i think white might even offer a rook
trade if he wants yeah
nice yeah win black's pawn in the center
black is temporarily a pawn up but look
how many weaknesses black has uh okay he
does go for this pawn uh push magnus is
rushing slightly i'm slightly concerned
about that uh for him but he's created a
passport white's a pawn now is a runner
and then get the rook behind the pawn
and there you see he really made a very
fast move pre-move
yep so black's giving check and magnus
while rushing towards his pawn so it's
now a race it's about whether white's
pawn is quick enough to run up the board
black's rook might have to give itself
up for that uh but it's just about
whether the black king can start doing
its own damage magnus decided not to go
and grab pawns himself he's banking on
this one
guy alice the airport uh running up the
board and magnus's king is now going to
go and support this pawn every move is
pretty much forced but magnus is just
clearly playing by instinct playing like
this because he's not using when he's
not using the clock and now you can see
a pawn race is he going to bring his
rook back and challenge the blackrook
yeah he is that's a nice tactic it's
going to get really complicated but yeah
okay there we go this rook offers itself
up but it's purely to distract black's
rook away from defending the white apron
promoting yeah five seconds
okay five seconds and he takes the white
rook white makes a new queen and it's
queen versus rook black's pawns are all
uh a bit loose as well so no fortress in
this game it's just about whether blacks
far advanced pawn can promote later
okay he's pushing it but white can stop
that pawn with this queen or i can give
a check or two first if he wants as well
okay that has had has happened there and
now just go back and stop this black
pawn in the center there we go and
actually a couple of pawns now under
fire because pawns are going to be
dropping off in case if he gives a spike
check
king will move but still the problem
persists you know there's two pawns on
priest the pawn uh on the f6 square and
the far advanced pawn and now well all
he has to do is just
move his king to attack the rook and
he's done that 12 seconds no more checks
for black black has to put his rook on a
passive square the black pawn drops and
now it's just a matter of time the white
queen is going to overpower the black
rook uh she has easy roots into the
black position black's pawns are just
too weak i think any moment the black
rook also has no safe squares to park
itself on
okay it goes active and uh and he's
taking his earphones out he's getting
ready
to give up
one more move the queen will attack the
black pawns and that's game over but
aneesh geary he keeps playing
okay a couple of last moves here i
suppose i mean i suppose his only hope
is to get something like queen versus
brook nothing else on the board which is
still winning for white but
it's it's a bit tricky to win yeah i
think he's just going through the
motions the most painful thing just to
resign
wait for five minutes and let him suffer
are the players allowed to go and have a
walk maybe he could go
chill out a little bit go and get some
sushi
his legs are there yeah he's about to go
that's it that's it it's over magnus
carlsen takes the lead in the match
against anish giri